ecaussinnes entre mons et charleroi
cadre chaque lundi de pentecôte depuis
1903 d'un goûter matrimoniale une façon
élégante de parler d'une sorte de foire
aux célibataires qui rassemble hommes et
femmes de toutes générations et selon un
rite immuable vers la sec qui stéphane
aubert ces dames se sont mis sur leur
trente-et-un ces messieurs ont revêtu
leurs plus beaux atours et tous ont le
même objectif trouver l'âme soeur
pour cela il faut remplir des
formulaires et les critères sont plutôt
sélectif trop gentil élégant et puis
c'est yvette est venu spécialement de
douai pour faire une rencontre peut-être
avec un belge quant à dany c'est sa
seconde participation en espérant que
cette fois sera la bonne
on se demande toujours ce qu'est ce
qu'on va tomber parce que bon c'est vrai
que
je n'aime pas les critères qu'on demande
à frangy en joie
un peu plus loin les mariés forme les
couples même tranche d'âge quelques
points communs et voilà nous n'avons pas
les photos lors des inspections alors
nous formons des les couples suivant les
dires des gens sur leur fiche
d'inscription est alors parfois nous
formons un très beau couple john a sorti
physiquement
et puis parfois c'est vraiment sont
vraiment à côté de la plaque
quelques minutes plus tard les coeurs
palpitent c'est l'heure des résultats
bonjour nous ont fait comprendre comment
sur la gauche on est vraiment bon pour
moi le mot déception pour les uns bonne
surprise pour les autres quoi qu'il en
soit il y aura certainement quelques
coeurs à prendre dans - ce soir à et
coty
avant de bijoux dorés